Viewing The Flintstones through adult eyes
reveals a complex world with a lot of dark
or problematic moments.
You wouldn't notice them if you're a kid,
but if you're a grown up...you yabba-dabba-do.
While The Flintstones is clearly a riff on
the groundbreaking sitcom The Honeymooners,
it does make a few notable changes.
The Flintstones is a bit more of an equal
opportunity offender when it comes to domestic
abuse.
Ralph Kramden threatened to beat his wife
so often that his verbal promise of violence
became a TV catchphrase…
"Bang.
Zoom."
Audiences never actually saw Ralph get physical
with his wife but viewers of The Flintstones
saw it work the other way around.
Fred often threatened Wilma, but that's where
it stopped.
However, when Fred did something Wilma didn't
like, which was often, she'd clock him on
the head, drop heavy objects on his feet,
fling him across the room, and who knows what
else.
"Wilma, no, not in the head!"
Of course, Fred wasn't the easiest caveman
to live with.
He had serious anger management issues, he
constantly twisted the truth and his views
on the role of women in society really did
belong in the Stone Age.
"How many times have I told you, a woman's
place is in the home!"
For a show that took place millions of years
ago, The Flintstones is surprisingly progressive
about a number of issues.
In the 1960s, it was revolutionary that the
series was open about how Barney and Betty
Rubble couldn't naturally conceive a child
like the Flintstones, and how upset they were
about it.
It was a major TV event in February 1963 when
Wilma gave birth to Pebbles, and afterwards,
the Rubbles spend an inordinate amount of
time hanging out with the new arrival, they
just want a baby so bad.
As a last resort, they make a wish on a falling
star.
The next morning, their wish has apparently
been granted and they find a baby boy at their
doorstep…a supernaturally strong orphan
named Bamm Bamm.
"Wheeee!
Oh, Barney, we've got our very own baby."
However, the couple still had a long way to
go before they could call Bamm Bamm their
own.
Adult viewers will certainly feel some empathy,
as the Rubbles jump through legal hoops to
adopt the little powerhouse, and are only
granted custody at the last minute.
The whole ordeal mentally drains Barney to
the point where he wants to take his own life.
"Goodbye cruel world."
Luckily, Fred shows up just in time to save
the day and Bamm Bamm's new daddy.
The Flintstones wouldn't be The Flintstones
without animals, birds, and other creatures
performing all kinds of household and mechanical
tasks.
The modern Stone-Age family seems to have
an animal for every job, a mastodon instead
of a shower, a monkey/bird tag team inside
a record player, a swordfish for a kitchen
knife, and an artistic bird that functions
as a prehistoric Polaroid camera, just to
name a few.
You have to wonder what these animals actually
think of Fred.
"The guy's a pig, a neanderthal!
"You're dead to me, can opener!"
It doesn't seem like the animals on The Flintstones
are getting paid, or have any freedom whatsoever.
In other words, the humans of The Flintstones
have enslaved animals, forcing all creatures
great and small into a being beasts of burden.
While this is cruel, some animals have it
worse than others.
Birds' tails are constantly being yanked.
A pelican serves as a trash can, meaning people
force-feed it garbage.
And, possibly worst of all, a variety of poor
creatures are forced to sacrifice their entire
lives for construction and mining.
"I've had just about enough of these lazy
f---s using us as slave labor!"
"The uprising is upon us!"
Like most sitcoms of the 1960s, The Flintstones
was not serialized.
Each episode completely stood on its own,
with Fred, Wilma, Barney, and Betty getting
into some kind of hairy situation and resolving
it by the end of the episode.
Kids can accept this.
They can enjoy shows on a surface level.
Adults may want to know more about developments
in The Flintstones universe, such as what
happens after the events in the episode "Dino
and Juliet."
In this comic version of Romeo and Juliet,
Fred Flintstone and a new neighbor get into
a heated dispute.
Instead of the warring factions' teenage offspring
falling in love, their pet dinosaurs do.
Dino falls instantly head over heels for Juliet,
the cute new sauropod in town.
"Well if that don't beat the bush!
Dino's in love!"
As lovers are wont to do, Dino and Juliet
steal away for some privacy...which results
in the birth of more than a dozen babies.
Never again on The Flintstones are Juliet
or her children with Dino seen.
Apparently, he's an absentee father and the
love-'em-and-leave-'em type.
After a few years on the air, sitcoms tend
to bring in a new character to breathe fresh
life into the series.
Homeless teen Luke showed up on Growing Pains,
Cousin Oliver appeared on The Brady Bunch,
and The Simpsons mocked the entire concept
with a random character named Roy.
"Adding a new character is often a desperate
attempt to boost low ratings."
"Yo, yo!
How's it hanging, everybody?"
"Morning, Roy."
The Flintstones pioneered this move back in
1965 with the arrival of a tiny, smug alien
named the Great Gazoo.
The little green E.T. had been sent through
space and time to prehistoric Earth as punishment
for making a doomsday device on his home planet.
Gazoo clearly has seen his share of dark places.
"Get off me, you big lummox!"
"Gazoo!
Where have you been?"
Fred and Barney discover him, and rather than
report him to the government, they befriend
him, although Gazoo mainly seems to call them
"dumb-dumbs" and magically disappear whenever
Fred is talking to him, which gives the impression
that Fred has mental issues.
Or maybe the Great Gazoo isn't real at all...and
Fred and Barney have been ingesting some unknown
substances with mysterious side-effects.
Yes...The Flintstones is a cartoon, and it
passed strict network standards in the conservative
early 1960s.
But, somehow, it managed to sneak in the occasional
dirty joke for the adults in the room.
In one episode, Fred and Barney are watching
TV when they lose reception.
Fred asks if everything is in working order
and Barney immediately hits Fred with a comeback
that would make most parents blush in front
of their kids.
"How's your antennae?"
"Fine, Fred.
How's yours?"
It would also seem that they had "adult films"
way back in the Stone Age.
While getting a check-up, a doctor holds up
Fred's x-ray, prompting Flintstone to joke,
"How about it, Doc?
Flintstone in an x-ray-ted picture!"
While these man-cave jokes were right up Fred
and Barney's alley, we can't help but wonder
how Wilma and Betty would react.
"Bang."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.